all right today we have something much
requested
by the audience we are going to be
speaking with
vosh not vaush not
va'ash but vosh a popular streamer
debater
progressive socialist with nearly 300
000 subscribers
now i think it's important my audience
understands that
i don't call people socialists when
they're not socialist you're an
actual bonafide socialist yeah i'd like
to think i am at least
cool all right we'll we'll get into that
and now what i'm always curious anytime
i deal with anybody who uses
a pseudonym how did you decide to
operate under a pseudonym
i was a big old art kid back in high
school you know every art kid wants to
draw comics or at least a lot of them do
okay gosh was the name of a character
that i wanted to draw anyway when i
started doing the content i just decided
to use it as a placeholder name and it
stuck
so it's catchy enough and i'm guessing
for privacy reasons it's not the worst
thing
oh sure yeah but uh i mean people go
either way but i think vosh it's nice
and catchy anyway so i don't mind
so let's let's talk a little bit i mean
maybe to get into our conversation
we are coming off the heels of an
election in which uh donald trump lost
joe biden won
senate control is unclear at this point
um uh uh and and we're we're sort of
trying to figure out what what is the
next step
for someone with your perspective as a
socialist where both joe biden
and donald trump are very different from
you uh in terms of their politics
do you see replacing trump with biden as
a good thing
how good of a thing oh undeniably uh
this is something that i learned when i
looked into the writings of people like
engels and lenin and mao you see
socialists are
at least as i understand it most
comfortable making our arguments
in a democratic or a bourgeois
democratic system that is to say
in a system where we have sort of this
veneer of corporate democracy where
people
expect things like rights and
representation you can make arguments
like
hey couldn't we be doing this better in
outright fascist societies or societies
which have become so nationalistic that
national interest takes precedence over
class
interest it's really difficult to get
those arguments across
that's why we typically lose whenever
fascists take power
we're the first ones out we're the
biggest threat so preserving the system
for a little bit longer under joe biden
vastly vastly preferable um
to the threat of our democratic
institutions crumbling also just frankly
biden's just better
like objectively in a number of issues
climate change healthcare can't argue
with that
so very clearly you're you're uh make
you're making it obvious that you are
not an accelerationist accelerationism
being the idea that
there would be a shortcut to your
eventual ideal
uh arrangement of of affairs by having
society crumble by having those
institutions crumble that that would in
some way accelerate or more quickly get
us to that end point
you you very clearly don't subscribe to
that the conditions need to be right for
that if things collapsed right now
we would not be the ones to take power
we do not have that kind of uh
infrastructure established they would be
the ones to take power
in a system where it felt like chaos or
collapse would be
something which would inspire some kind
of you know um
natural organic democratic control i
could get behind
that but that is not the world we live
in right now what would happen in your
mind if if things crumbled
instead of a socialist utopia what would
we most most likely see
oh man i mean if things i mean depending
on how things crumbled right now the
general prevailing attitude in this
country is fear and nationalism
we would probably set up some sort of if
not one singular at least a collection
of ethno-nationalist communities
um the direction this country is taking
right now
the world is controlled at least in
chaos by the most
militarily prepared and right now i
think a large number of trump supporters
are
ready they believe they're on the
precipice of having to
take hold of a dead world whereas a lot
of progressive and left-leaning people
you know god bless them whatever
um i don't think are ready for that and
for that reason if
you know push comes to shove i'm just
not confident that our chances i think
that we're going to go
dramatically far right i think we're
probably going to turn into an
isolationist ethno-nationalist state
and from that point forward we'll be
completely unable to affect the rest of
the world as its course changes and i
don't i don't want that
yeah okay so so far i completely agree
with you i think that if if we do see a
crumbling that some imagine
might lead to the ushering in of the
idealized socialist
circumstances i think we get exactly
what you're talking about
now uh under what circumstances do you
believe
that your socialist organization of the
country
would be most likely to be achieved what
what would happen
be between now and then leading up to it
we need to do a lot of cultural work and
we need to get people to
fixate on issues that actually affect
their lives what gets a trump supporter
out of bed what gets them angry at the
world
is it the state of their schools their
infrastructure their education
uh their their health care very rarely
no usually it's meaningless cultural
issues
you have trans people you have the
belief that blm is going to burn down
their suburb
these are nonsense scaremonger fear
issues these aren't reflective of
reality
and for that reason this is why we are
concern ourselves with the spread of
something called class consciousness we
want people to be concerned first and
foremost with the conditions that
actually affect their lives
and if we can do that and i believe we
can do that and people like bernie
sanders have shown
you can do that to lots of people if you
focus on the right arguments
um i think that we'll be in a position
where the predominant ideological trend
of this country will be won towards
radical workplace democracy as opposed
to radical isolationism
radical ethnic exclusionary behavior
that sort of thing
am i being too simplistic if i say that
for the time being
socialists and social democrats should
be united
because the next steps are identical for
both groups or at least they should be
no i think that's totally true i mean
we'll backstab each other later i'm sure
right historically yeah of course of
course
but for right now yeah we need to focus
on uh social democrats you consider
yourself one of course i don't know you
are
yeah because i've seen your content um
social democrats and socialists have a
lot in common in that we both
respect the belief that the economic
resources of our country should be
turned towards the well-being of the
people we should focus on
improving these base institutional needs
that we believe humans are entitled to
and that's great and i think that when
people are exposed to that they're
way less likely to associate their
well-being with these meaningless
cultural platitudes that trump
supporters or other
culture warriors like to obsess over for
now i think our interests are aligned
down the line
you know we'll have our arguments i'm
sure so now let's think ahead a little
bit if we
just so to really kind of continue
exploring your your world view
imagine that the social democrats
get the things they want we have
democratization of the workplace
we are sort of raising the floor and and
putting some ceiling in and make sure
making sure nobody falls too far and
doing some of the things finland and
other northern european places have done
social democrats get their way okay once
you get to that point
what mechanism do you imagine would
usher in
socialism how do we get to where
every business for example socializes
ownership of the means of production by
what mechanism
is that installed or enacted well you
mentioned workplace democracy which i
like i think that's a very good trojan
horse for socialist ideals because it
literally is the seizure of the means of
production
in a society in which every workplace is
democratic that is to say there's some
there's some kind of democratic
framework that allows you to vote in or
vote out individuals managers that sort
of thing
and the means of those firms the wealth
the resources are collectively owned
amongst those who work there
if you have every firm in a country that
adheres to those principles
you have what would have been called 150
years ago a dictatorship of the
proletariat
not very well named but essentially
because dictatorship didn't have the
connotation back then that it does now
a worker's state well that let me let's
pause for a second though
maybe we might have a different idea of
what i in fact it's very clear we have a
different idea about what
democratization of the workplace would
mean so when i think about
democratization of the workplace i'm
talking about
for companies above a certain size you
must have
um uh board representation from
employees
uh when you you know so there's a list
of things but i think it's probably
it certainly doesn't sound like it would
go as far as what you're talking about
which sounds like it would almost
be a socialization of the means of
production that would be the goal for me
at least i think that
democratically minded people are very
susceptible to arguments in favor of the
democratization of the workplace in the
way that i describe it
i think that once you look at um a firm
and you look at its traditional
organization which
is pretty dictatorial in its natural
state you know here in the states
you don't control who your manager is or
your boss is you work there and you do
what you're told or you're fired
um i think that people are very amicable
to the idea that there can be an
improvement on that system there's very
very positive data coming out of
countries um
well all around the world in different
material conditions suggesting that
worker cooperatives are
a pretty effective way of organizing
firms and it leaves people happier and
in some cases it's even more efficient
so the question is
how can we sell people on the idea that
that system
which necessitates the destruction of
the bourgeois the class
you no longer have an owner after all
it's collective how do we incentivize
that how do we encourage people to move
that direction
but is your view so there's a dramatic
difference between
everybody is convinced and sold on the
idea
that that's how businesses should be
owned
versus it is imposed as this is how it
must be done or otherwise it is not a
legal business it sounds like you're
leaning at least for now more in the
direction of saying
you feel like you have the facts on your
side and you could convince people to do
it that way
are you not suggesting that at a certain
point the only legal way to organize a
business
would be socialized ownership i don't
think you can compel democracy
i don't think it works very well i think
that when
socialism arrives in the states should
it arrive nobody will call it socialism
they will view it as a natural extension
of a series of economic and
worker-related rights that they've been
building upon for a good time before
that
with regards to whether or not this
should be pushed for in like an
autocratic way
though an autocratic sort of delivery of
democracy is
a little a little silly but it's
happened before yes um when we freed the
slaves of course the slave owners didn't
like that but we did it anyway and i
think we can agree that was a good thing
the people who will be pushing back on
this aren't going to be the democratic
populist it's probably going to be the
owners of these businesses and that's
the ultimate
conflict you know how well how
significantly can the interests of the
majority
be assigned precedence over the
interests of a very small
very elite group of landed modern
aristocrats
we're going to continue our conversation
with vosh and the full interview will be
posted on the youtube channel but on the
podcast tv and radio show we are going
to go to a break
what i find so interesting about this is
that there are some socialists who will
email me
or leave me voicemails that essentially
defend
the government imposition of socializing
ownership of businesses
as not being such an imposition as not
being autocratic or authoritarian
what i'm hearing you say more is that
you simply don't think that that's the
right approach and that you could win
essentially i hate to use
such a such a silly term but the battle
of ideas and convince people that this
is the way to go
i would hope so i mean with um uh like
take for example osha you know uh yeah
work and safety um when this was imposed
there was a number there was quite a bit
of pushback from you know
business uh business leaders and
lobbyists and what have you
they didn't want these positions they
don't want the government interfering
with this sort of thing but generally
speaking now in hindsight i think we can
reflect on that and think like
it was probably okay are there going to
be some people whose feathers are
ruffled
by any imposition whatsoever of like a
democratic standard in the workplace
undeniable but you want to minimize that
because as it stands
the bourgeois you know the landed elite
they have a tremendous amount of
cultural and media
influence and the more they push back
against this
the more the proletariat the workers are
going to believe it's not in their
interest either
it's in my interest to sell this to
people
as effectively and as ideologically as
possible because then
if we do come to not blows but come to
terms with it
i would much rather have a vast vast
majority of the population against a
group of lobbyists and maybe five
percent
of people who think it's in their best
interest that corporations remain
autocratic
than a culture war between socialists
and
capitalists i think that we're much
better off selling it to people that way
i i want to get to some more of that um
uh when donald trump has said a number
of times now this will never be a
socialist country
i'm quick to point out the the sort of
silliness of being able to say
that something will never happen we just
don't know that things that would be
unimaginable tend to happen relatively
quickly in history i think it's a silly
thing to say in principle
i also think it's silly because there
are essentially no actual socialists in
any positions of power in the united
states
so that the risk of socialism anytime
soon
seems very small i'm glad for you to
fact check me on those two things but my
my question was more about time frame
how long
in your mind would the transition you
would like to see
take realistically i know if you
convince everybody tomorrow it could
happen quickly but
understanding the world that we live in
the country we live in is this a 10-year
project is this a 50-year project
the problem is i don't think people
understand the extent to which they're
collect
again the socialist framework i don't
think people most people in this country
understand the extent to which the
wealthy are behind a lot of the
underlying infrastructural systemic
issues we have
if you look at anything from media to
education to healthcare any of these
things that really impact people's lives
if you dig deep enough eventually at the
root of it
you get i mean it sounds simplistic but
a collection of greedy people who have
landed interests who work in the you
know in their own interest and you can't
do anything about it because they're
powerful and you're not
and i think that we get distracted by
this with all these culture war issues
and right now we are more distracted i
think than we ever have been we are
obsessed with this idea
that the heart and soul of this country
is being fought over by either antifa
or by like patriot prayer like militia
groups
when in reality underneath all of that
and of course they side with blm in
every conceivable cultural matter
but underneath that these two groups
fighting they share a common enemy
i don't think there's much class
consciousness in this country right now
but
given all of that what is the timeline
i write i don't think there's any
realistic possibility of this timeline
being accelerated until the consequences
of climate change exacerbates the
american people's negative attitudes
towards the people who got us in this
position
if the country is really being battered
down like people are losing their lives
entire cities are being flooded or
typhooned
i think at that point there's a very
real chance that the collective
animosity against the people
the exxon executives who lied about data
the government officials who covered it
up
that might be a boiling point but at the
moment it's a slow
steady battle um where we will have very
little
relative influence compared to the
fascists so
in terms you mentioned the cultural
issues i want to talk about this a
little bit
um my view on political correctness is
that it's a perfectly reasonable thing
to criticize but i'm not going to be
using it as a dog whistle for
conservatism nationalism fascism or any
of that stuff
my view about um so-called identity
politics is
i don't want identity used as a cudgel
to silence people
but we should understand that one's
identity can bring perspectives to the
table that are valuable and unique and
that should be welcome
so you know i kind of have this this
view that all of these
culture type issues speech type issues
that the wright likes to talk about
there's like two percent about it that
that resonates with me and 98
where they're misusing it and
exaggerating it and using it to suppress
speech they don't like etc
where are you on those types of issues
oh it's completely i mean i'm very much
in favor of intersectional analysis
i graduated with a degree in sociology i
would have to be if i wanted to pay any
respect to my major
let's face it when when conservatives
talk about issues like um
like cancer culture or like political
correctness or like identity politics
where you they genuinely are using this
as sort of a
broader dog whistle against like
progressivism as a concept right because
where the right uses identity politics
religiously when they can get away with
it the right uses cancer culture
whatever the hell that means these days
religiously when they can get away with
it i don't think they're attacking these
issues in good faith and i think the
thought leaders who are pushing these
narratives are in many cases being paid
to do so
because the longer they can keep their
fan bases obsessed with these
misunderstandings of issues that aren't
even real
issues the less time they have to
understand how
you know hard they're being taken uh for
by these by these thought leaders by the
people who pay them
you've debated a ton of these people and
i some of them i've also debated i think
you do a far better job that than i do
you've been on with jessie lee peterson
you've been on with tim poole uh like i
think i
just want to say by the way your jlp
conversation phenomenal really
thank you thank you yeah no but in all
seriousness i i actually am curious
i mean you have a facility with where i
struggle sometimes
is i'm identifying where their argument
is nonsense
but i have less facility to in a pithy
way exposing
why their argument is nonsense and i'm
sort of dancing around and that type of
thing
what has been your sort of like training
and
and how do you prepare for these things
is it simply reading about the subject
matter do you research the people you'll
be debating how does it work
i try to prepare as little as possible
because what i find is that these
debates very rarely end up being
nuanced discussions of policy or history
and usually end up being a show of force
um usually these online conservative
thought leaders whatever fascists
wherever they land on the spectrum the
people who follow them follow them
because they think they're an
intellectual titan they're respected as
some sort of you know
strong grandiose sjw crusher and i think
that generally speaking what these
arguments
come down to is who can insult the other
person as effectively and viciously
as possible while making them feel like
a fool when it comes to like
actual nuance discussion of issues
honestly i just feel like they don't pay
enough respect to the issues they're
gaining to talk about for it to even be
worth my time to do any kind of special
investment
um so it's really these are rhetorical
battles not substantive battles oh oh
yeah
yeah i've had maybe two or three
substantive arguments out of hundreds of
rhetorical debates
well what i found is i mean when you
boil it down all political engagement is
rhetoric at the end of the day very few
people care about policy
so what i found is finding that line
between people it's good to be mean to
and people it's good to be nice to and
that's been more difficult than any
other distinction i've had to make
with my debate opponents and i'm trying
to get better about that
some people you look way better if
you're kind and quiet and sort of you
know
not just you know not uh not uh
submissive but you know
not aloof right right receptive and with
some people you really just have to tear
them down
and i think that it's honestly quite fun
to find out what you can get away with
in both of those
situations and i i quite like being able
to do it for a living
now the the question that i think all of
us at some point haven't i've had these
phases like i used to have right wingers
on my show all the time and debate them
like earl in the early years of the show
the homophobes the supply ciders
the you know you name it right whatever
and then i had periods where i stopped
doing it because
it wasn't so much that i got bored but i
realized maybe what you've realized
which is
we're not really talking about policy
these are really performances
to a certain degree and i kind of just
go back and forth about
it is it enough to say this is
entertaining for the audience and i can
make somebody look
like their ideas are wrong even if we
don't actually
do anything substantive is that not
enough i i just kind of go back and
forth about what the value in the
proposition the value proposition
is yeah oh my community is full of
former alt-righters and conservatives
who have been pulled over
if not just by me than at the very least
by other people some by you you've been
mentioned quite a few times
um and i think that for for me frankly
i'm an advocate
i don't care what i have to do to get
people on board with socialism
if i had to juggle pies and smash my
face into one of them every once in a
while and i felt that would somehow in
some way convince people
i would go for that route i feel that
the entertainment element is essential
this is one of the ways the lefties lost
the online space
right lefty online engagement
politically is very measured you've seen
the video essays i'm sure very measured
very artistic
conservatives will throw up meme
compilations three times a day
they'll do sjw they'll go to a they'll
go to a
woman's rights rally and just make like
blubbering noises in the face of like
activists
they don't care and they find it
delightful and they get lots and lots of
engagement
and while i don't necessarily want to
sing to that level i don't think i could
because i think my arguments are a
little less juvenile than those
i think that at the end of the day
people gravitate towards things
they find fun so we have to be able to
nail that for them how do you make
being a socialist or a progressive or
god
not a fascist fun yeah
that i don't there's this guy i don't
even know if he still makes content to
be honest
he his name is carl benjamin he's a
british guy he i think at one point he
was operating under the name sargon of
akkad
and he once confronted me for using
so-called clickbait youtube titles
and when we got down to it i i said i'm
coming up with titles to encourage
people to watch the content that because
i think that
that's what i want them to do and as
long as these titles are not deceptive
i'm not really sure i even understand
what the argument is and it's it's
that type of the you're sort of buying
your
the way i see it is i'm using an
interesting title
or covering a cartoonish trump rally to
get people in the universe
to then hopefully come back for the tax
analysis
and the discussion of policy and so on
and so forth i don't think that there's
anything wrong with that i just wish the
left were better at it
yeah yeah absolutely and they are so
much better than us
take um steve bannon for example you
know targeting like young
in-cell gamer communities online and
deliberately trying to pull them into
the alt-right
they are ruthless about uh you know um
uh trying to grab any community they can
um but i feel like they're very
hypocritical when they criticize us
likewise that same
man uh carl you just described has said
publicly that he will not debate me
after two debates with me where he
didn't do great um
because i make money from the debates
that i do
doesn't he make money he does make money
from the debates he does yeah that's
oh is the argument that because you're a
socialist you shouldn't make money
he's yeah that is definitely one
component of the argument socialism is
when you don't make money for the work
you do that's
weird yeah i mean at politicon a couple
years ago there was this surreal moment
where i'm trying to remember hassan
[ __ ]
was on stage debating i think charlie
kirk
and at a certain point something crazy
happened
where someone from or jankuger from the
audience
yelled something and charlie kirk made a
similar argument about how
i live like a capitalist every day he
can make money because he's a capitalist
and why is jenk but it's like jenks also
a capitalist he's just not he
he's you know he's just not a fascist
he's a social democrat or whatever gent
considers himself
socialists are all about keeping the
fruit of your labor the idea of
socialism meaning that you can't keep
the fruit of your labor is ridiculous
right in other words if you're
generating if you're i mean listen i
hate to go into the labor
labor theory of value but if you're
generating value from this debate by
getting an
i i as a social democrat believe you
should be compensated in proportion with
the value you generated
yeah you know completely i think and it
all gets really weird it all gets really
fussy especially with um
online content because the lines between
like a worker and owner blur
a little bit i think that there's a lot
of really nuanced discussion that you
can that you can have on this but when
people like carl are saying like oh
you make money from this so i won't dane
to debate you when you get to that level
like i think it's pretty clear that
you're trying to find excuses
i think people like him and other people
on the right online
are terrified of people like myself and
of you
because i think that we're we're
catching up we're trying to establish a
much more substantive progressive
uh and sometimes socialist front on this
website and we're doing it better
than they were able to a couple years
ago when they had the front foot you
know
now as far as your uh operation is it
just you or or do you have
as some might call them uh colleagues
some might call them employees
or is it or is it a solo shop for now i
have uh i have two people predominantly
who help me i have a content manager who
helps manage some of my social media
and i have a website manager who manages
my the website that i stream on
both of them are compensated a
percentage and they're given complete
creative freedom of their work so i try
my best to live to the standard that i
set
and i would like to believe that i you
know compensate very generously but
as i do better in the future i would
look to even raise their pay because i
could not have done this by myself
so it's not um you guys are three-way
partners in this and you've completely
socialized the profit centers
no for smaller industries or not
industries even
for smaller firms like this one like uh
like a youtube channel
yes um there's such an asymmetrical
distribution of responsibility that it's
difficult too right right that's one of
the issues which is why
that with regards to um worker
cooperatives i can understand arguments
for traditional
uh firm ownership for really small
businesses especially in media or
heavily specialized industries where
uh essentially the other people are
acting as assistants to one person's
like
uh unique talent with regards to
whatever it is they're doing
wow but it's it's an ongoing process and
i'm um you know i'm interested in seeing
more
content creators online explore similar
models
very interesting yeah no i think that
certainly one of the difficulties
in terms of talking about
democratization of the workplace
is businesses that are relatively small
and by relatively small i mean
even you know like eight employees 10
employees i still consider to be
relatively small you you might you know
that's more employees than i have but
you might you might sort of draw the
line at a different place
to kind of wrap up our conversation so
next two months um
do you have any doubt that joe biden is
inaugurated as president
what do you most want to see him do what
are you most worried that he will do
um with regards to joe biden as much as
i've looked over it i can't
think of a single supreme court action i
can't think of any avenue the trump
administration has to legitimately
overturn
the the president-elect's uh victory it
would have to be
maybe there's some incredibly obsequious
250 year old statute that they can
interpret
i have no idea but i i imagine that with
all the fussing and whining we're seeing
it's going to end up exactly how we
expect it to which is
very embarrassingly for trump um
with regards to the best and worst
things that we're going to see
unfortunately there's not much of a
standard that i can set for joe biden's
performance because it looks like we're
not going to be able to take the senate
if he doesn't have the senate there's a
lot of stuff that
that i would like to see that i can't
even expect he would be able to do he
does have a plan for one
first day executive actions which i'm
looking forward to seeing but yeah
i guess my overall worry my main worry
is that there are certain elements
within the democratic party that are
going to attempt to blame the
progressive wing for their performance
in this past election aoc has already
taken a lot of fire for this
from well from certain people i you know
i don't want to get into it too much but
that would be very disappointing to me
um for the thing that i'm looking
forward to the most frankly i want to go
back to bashing liberals i
um it's exhausting all the time arguing
with fascists they are
so so dumb i want to advance the
state of class consciousness amongst
people who i think are just at the cusp
of it you know
progressive liberals i think that if you
make good arguments to these people they
can move over
um but like arguing fascists it's like
herding cats i look forward to
challenging systems in power
that are reasonable again or at least
more standard
that's uh i mean that that's that's we
we agree
we definitely are agreeing on more than
i imagined maybe this is the
where we could end it do you think an
open-faced omelette is a pizza where do
you come down on that
i am uh i am a um culinary and
linguistic descriptivist i think that if
you want to call it a pizza you have to
and i will respect your right to do so
so an open face omelette you're fine
calling a pizza absolutely
wow 100 that's huge that's huge and if
you put a tortilla under it then it's
absolutely a pizza right
oh oh i mean that just i mean that nails
at home not that it needed
that affirmation but if you show that
far and you can go you can wrap that
around much as you want pop-tart a
burrito absolutely i'll take it
wait a pop-tart is a pizza now no
pop-tarts a burrito
oh i'm sorry oh okay okay that's
actually that's that i've not thought of
that i've not thought of but we will uh
wow that now my mind is blown i'm gonna
have to think about that one a little
bit i'm hungry over here
um okay well listen we've been speaking
with
vosh who now is ready to crest
300 000 subscribers on youtube
is a streamer debater progressive
socialist
not yet completely socialized in terms
of the means of production within his
organization but presented a very good
argument as to why he is not
and uh i i can't thank you enough i'm so
glad we were able to do this
yeah likewise i hope we're able to speak
again in the future hopefully under
slightly less tumultuous circumstances
completely and totally agree